on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the veteran alex wood
wood 30 years of age he's in his eighth
year at the big league level that's what
he has done at 12 start 6-3 the 4-0-9
era with 65 strikeouts in 66 innings two
he gets called strike three a fastball
right in there and he could not get off
a swing
high in the air toward the pitcher's
mound
and this is not going to be easy look
out and caught by the third baseman
good start for alex wood hayes go down
in order frankie montos kype is going to
do everything he can to rip off the rear
view mirror and completely forget about
the outing in
and a texas
splitter and yastrimsky strikes out on
pitching the dirt
so two outs here in the bottom of the
first now the 3-2 once again and it's
swung on this is a fly ball to right
that's playable and pender about two
steps to his right now in a couple and
he makes the catch montas works in one
two three
bottom of the first and after one game
two of the series the a's and the giants
no score the three best records in the
national league all in the national
league west
strike three call on the outside corner
with the slider
number one up comes chad pinder
that's it strike three call again
same pitch with which he
got lowry looking two down 3-2 pitch
is strike three call
he got the call this time alex woods
strikes out the side and all looking
nice inning for the giants left-hander
[Applause]
here's the one two the crawford swung
out and missed down he goes on a split
down and away
good pitch second strikeout for montage
two and two the count dickerson at first
base head to right field
dickerson will stop at second that's the
first hit of the game and now the bases
are loaded for casalli he's ready he
throws and it's swung on and missed out
he goes circus sally strikes out third
strikeout for montas and he can get out
of the inning now with a picture coming
up out of the stretch and the 2-2 pitch
is swung on a ground ball left side to
his left at third chapman has it goes to
first for the out and the inning is over
montas works out of it wood is not 5'3
the giants leave the bases loaded
left-hander turns the one strike offer
breaking ball lined into right center to
base it
that is over solano and baba momentarily
by duggar and taking an extra 90 feet as
elvis he'll slide in safely a single and
an e8 elvis kept the head up recognized
that duggar misplayed it in right center
one-two pitch
strike three called on the inside
kind of a delayed call from
lance barrett two down and now matt
chapman comes up with two on and two out
[Applause]
to the backstop
coming in to score and he will score
that's elvis andrews so the a's get a
run they'll take it as that one just
sailed right past casalli
struck him out that's already six
strikeouts for alex wood but it's a run
for the a's
here's the 1-0 breaking ball slap
through the right side a base hit
between wade and solano and pinners
aboard with his first hit in the series
now there's a swing and a high fly ball
hit to right yaz moving easily over to
his left under it reaches up and one
hands it
fairly shallow right field so two down
[Applause]
now swing ground ball hits softly the
second solano's got it slings it over
the first
for the hour 002 was called out on
strikes his first time never did swing
the bat
0-2 pitch swung out and missed a
fastball that was maybe six or seven
inches off the outside
and that's all from on thomas
now there is a check swing and on appeal
rule to swing
by tim timmons the first base umpire
strike three that's eight strikeouts in
five innings
there he goes
and it's a swing and a miss murphy's
throw
not quite in time
murphy had a throw from his knees and he
made a pretty good throw
maybe just could not get as much on it
as normal
well it's a great adjustment by sean
murphy behind the plate to try to get
that throw off
and now the 2-1 delivery is the ground
ball left side taking it short elvis has
it fires over to first with the out
and duggar able to go to third elvis had
to go slightly to his right to feel the
chopper and reading that duggar goes
from second to third now a runner at
third and here comes lamont way junior
fastball there's a drive in the deep
right field hit really well way back
there still going adios
pelanta
over the 20-foot high wall to the left
of the 365 marker and into those seats
and that puts the giants ahead two to
one but one of the eight one of the last
road trips for the years this year will
take them to toronto
if they can go here's the bouncy ball
right side slowly hit charging crawford
underhand flip not in time and olson
beats it out so just a little roller on
the infield and past the pitcher's mount
and the glove flip by crawford not in
time one ball no strikes it's on the way
and it's swung on a ground ball into
left for a base hit a solid single olson
goes the second turning he's going to
third and the throw is not going to be
in time
heads up based running by matt olson on
a base hit to left by jed lowry and the
answer at the corners with one out in
the six
instead of chad pinder mitch moreland is
gonna hit against dominic leone and now
here's the pitch to moreland swung on a
ground ball into right for a base hit
olson has scored lowry's the third
they're going to hold him there and
these tie it up
mitch moreland comes off the bench and
delivers a ground ball base hit through
the right side hole big spot in this
game right here right now two on two out
2-2 pitch is hit hard diving play lowry
has it his throw to first duggars out
what a play by jed lowry on the rim of
the outfield grass getting down in the
dirt takes the one hopper gets up throws
to first for the out and duggar is
retired and the giants fail to score
matt with another chance to extend the
hitting streak to 14 games
and mattel the long hold the pitch
fastball lifted down the right field
line you're stressing giving chase
toward the wall looking up it's gone in
opposite field two run homer for matt
chapman he shocks latel and the giants
and gives the a's a 4-2 lead
giants threatening here in the bottom of
the seventh giants only have three hits
tonight line drive base hit
wade heading home
giants have a run it's 4-3 donovan
solano
singled in the second flight out to
center in the fourth walked in the sixth
that ball is hit well deep left center
field hits on its way
down
solano
four to four here in the eighth inning
two and two the count now to duggar
whoa
he took it
and ice water in his veins to take that
one with two strikes and he got the call
and murphy is really upset and giving
baron some
some angry words there and bear went out
and got right in his face and here comes
bob melvin now to get between them
yeah he's got to try and keep his
catcher in the game
and the other reason murphy is upset
about is he's had that pitch call to
strike about a half dozen times tonight
and bob melvin has just been ejected
from the game
so brandon crawford's gonna have the
chance to be the hero here in the ninth
inning two on two out
crawford line drive left field base hit
kemp has it here comes wade the pick off
the throw and he is out they threw the
cutoff man and wade gets thrown out at
the play
go ahead run at third here in the 10th
one ball no strikes the lefty fires and
it's it high in the air to left
waiting for it is wade waiting for it to
come down
and he will make the catch here comes
brown here comes the throw not even
close seth slides across that is five
for oakland
one out and crawford's still at second
so stephen duggar will come up
up the middle
base head center field
perfect rounding third and there will be
no throw
steven duggar gets it done
down to the field eye bae's head
duggar the fastest runner to third the
ball juggled here's the relay home slave
and the ball game is over
the giants have tightened and now they
have won it